derrick is with us in minneapolis hi
derek how are you
hi thanks for doing thanks for taking my
question sure how can we help
well a couple things um when i was in
college i
had a ton of credit card debt and i said
i'd never do that again and kind of
worked my way out of it was pretty bad
and i was pre dave ramsey uh before i
knew about you
and my wife um she had a ton of credit
card debt and we worked really hard for
a year or two to get it paid off
recently i just bought a car from a guy
he asked me why i paid
cash for the card i could afford a
better car than that
and i said because i hate that so you
left your book and my car were the best
guess ever
so the question is twice now we've paid
off my wife's credit card we kind of
have things separated now
and now she wants to go back again to us
paying him off
because i'm kind of pushing the dave
hansen on him how do i get her to be
motivated and not go behind me back and
run a credit card debt again
why are your finances separated
well right away we were together we
paying off for credit cards is about 16
000
how long you've been married 14 years
yeah so why are your finances separated
and this is this
is this is why that was the only like i
looked my life to death because the only
battle we have is that after we paid
them off i thought we were done with
some
she told me she cut them up actually
watch her cut them up
then next year when we got her tax
returns back and that's kind of where we
paid her last thousand dollars on them
with her tax returns the next year
she said let's use the tax return to pay
off the credit cards there so we don't
have any credit cards
to have to worry about that to live nine
thousand dollars okay so you didn't
separate your accounts you never had
them together
no we add them together oh that's
impossible it's impossible that you had
them together because it's impossible
she has credit card debt
you don't know about if your finances
are together
right um my mom and dad were kind of
helping her on the side
it doesn't matter oh so they're i mean
they're paying the credit card bill so
she can hide it from you
pretty much yeah yeah so we separated
them for the next 14 years
and she asked me you know how much money
do you have so like that's the kind of
show and i think
she noticed i've saved up a ton of
wealth kind of using your system by
myself
and now she wants to get back on and do
this together it's not it's not my
system if you're not doing it together
yeah
okay and derek i'm going to tell you
this trying to do money stuff when you
guys got it you guys have a
marriage issue there's uh
i you know it it's tough trust me we
don't hardly ever fight
no no i'm not saying you you listen to
me some of the nastiest
fights are non-verbal and so
what i'm saying is is you guys need to
go sit down with a marriage therapist a
marriage counselor
and find out what this is that's
standing in the way of you all
connecting
because this money stuff has got to be
done together as a team
and it's putting the cards on the table
and being up front and reel
so you guys can make some decisions
about how you're going to move forward
your your probability
of continuing to build wealth at the
speed you should build wealth
is very low until you guys get on the
exact
same page and you're making you're doing
a monthly budget
together that both of you know where
every dollar is going
before it goes and you're both in
agreement on the basic tenets of how
you're going to handle money in
emergency fund you're going to be
debt-free we're not using credit cards
anymore
but your her off over there by herself
and then you're shocked
that she runs up a credit card bill
that's not right
well she she makes a ton of money
i don't care i'm asking yeah i know so i
could
literally i can pay off all the credit
card bill and i don't care
okay you guys need to combine
your freaking lives
you're not going to fix this otherwise
you're right you got a roommate dude
are y'all are y'all splitting who uses
the mayonnaise
who uses the mustard i mean who gets to
drink which
which beer in the refrigerator oh my
gosh yeah
you know y'all need to be on the same
page it's a
big deal man it's a big deal and you do
you do not grasp what you're missing out
on that and then you turn around acting
like somehow she's deficit
right because she's running you know you
said go run your own finances
and then you're shocked that she did
of course she did yeah and of course she
did whatever the flip she wanted to do
so i don't think this is her fault dude
i think it's yours yeah no and
again you guys it's pronoun problems you
keep saying i and she
has got to be we what are we doing
moving forward i think the first step
you guys need to take
is to get with a marriage counselor to
sit down and get real about your
situation
and what you want from the future it's
imperative
or you're going to keep going in circles
my friend